bon c'est bon t'es prêt pour aller voter
aux élections européennes de mais
maintenant qu'on a présenté les
institutions de l'union européenne
bah en fait pas tellement parce qu'on a
été un peu rapide sur le parlement
européen c'est justement pour ça qu'on
ira voter un bain a pas de problème tu
as cinq minutes tu expliques ça tout de
suite
[Musique]
bon déjà ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que
dans l'union européenne le parlement
européen est l'institution qui
représente les peuples des états membres
de l'union européenne
comment ça on dit ça principalement
parce que dans l'union européenne
les députés européens sont les seuls qui
sont élus au suffrage universel direct
donc par les citoyens il se choisit pays
par pays c'est ça c'est ça le nombre de
députés de chaque pays dépend du nombre
d'habitants de chaque pays en france on
a 60 14 eurodéputés et en année lire à 5
de plus en 2019
vu que la grande bretagne sort de
l'union européenne ok mais il sait quoi
le parlement européen en fait
le parlement européen a trois grandes
missions assez classique pour un
parlement sa principale mission ont
indiqué les législatives
ils votent et amandes donc modifier les
textes législatifs avec le conseil des
ministres de l'union européenne
du coup c'est eux qui créent les lois
européennes il n'y a pas de lois
européennes
on parle plutôt de directives ou de
règlement mais sinon contrairement à la
france où le parlement a la capacité de
faire lui-même des propositions de loi
le parlement européen ne peut pas
proposer de textes juridiques
ah non mais qui les proposent alors on
l'union européenne
il n'y a que la commission européenne
qui peut proposer des textes juridiques
hockey et ils font craindre à part voté
du coup à part voter les textes
juridiques deux eurodéputés décide avec
le conseil des ministres du budget
annuel de l'union européenne enfin pour
finir le parlement européen peut
contrôler l'exécutif de l'union
européenne donc la commission européenne
il peut par exemple censurer la
commission ou encore c'est lui qui élit
le président de cette même commission
européenne aussi tous les membres de la
commission doivent être approuvées par
le parlement
merci j'y vois plus clair par contre il
ya encore un truc que j'ai pas compris
quand on parle du parlement européen on
parle parfois de strasbourg parfois de
bruxelles mais il travaille ou les
députés européens
eh bien les 751 eurodéputés travail à la
fois à bruxelles et à strasbourg
la préparation des votes se fait à
bruxelles et les votes en assemblée
plénière se font à strasbourg quatre
jours par mois
bah du coup là c'est bon j'ai tout
compris et c'est quand le vote déjà
c'est en mai 2019 on va lire les
eurodéputés pour cinq ans ah mais je
suis pas inscrite sur les listes
électorales moi je pourrai pas voter
calme toi tout va bien tu as encore
jusqu'au 31 mars pour s'inscrire sur les
listes électorales
alors vas vite inscrire et dit aux gens
autour de toi de s'inscrire aussi
ouf merci bon j'espère que cette fois ci
tu as vraiment tout compris
tu vas pouvoir laïque et cette vidéo et
même t'abonner à cette chaîne pour ne
louper aucune prochaine vidéo merci
d'avoir écouté cette vidéo et à bientôt